we're nearing the home stretch of our
quest to find the inverse of this three
by three matrix here and the next thing
that we can do is find the determinant
of it which we already have a good bit
of practice doing so the determinant
the determinant of c
of our matrix i'll do that same color
c there are several ways that you could
do it
several ways that you could do it you
could say you could use the idea that
it's equal to you could take this top
row of the matrix and take the value of
each of those terms times the cofactor
times the corresponding cofactor and
take the sum there that's one technique
or you could do the technique where you
rewrite these first two columns and then
you take the product of the diagonals
and and of of the top to left diagonals
sum those up and then subtract out the
top the bottom the top right to the
bottom left i'll do the second one just
so that you can see that you get the
same result so let's see the determinant
is going to be equal to i'll rewrite all
of these things
so negative 1 negative 2 2
1 1
four five
and let me now
just to make it a little bit simpler
rewrite these first two columns
so negative one negative two two one
three four so the determinant is going
to be equal to
so let me write this down so you have
negative 1 times 1 times 5.
well that's just going to be negative 5
taking that product
then you have
negative 2
times one times three
well that's negative six
so we'll have negative six or you can
say plus negative six there and then you
have
two times two times four well that's
just four times 4 which is just 16.
so we have plus 16 and then we do
the top right to the bottom left so you
have negative 2 times 2 times 5. well
that's negative 4 times 5. so that is
negative
20 but we're going to subtract negative
20. so it's negative 4 times 5 negative
20 but we're going to subtract
negative 20. obviously that's going to
turn into adding negative adding
positive 20
then you have negative 1 times 1 times 4
which is negative 4 but we're going to
subtract these products so this is we're
going to subtract negative 4
and then you have 2 times 1 times 3
which is 6 but we have to subtract it so
we have subtracting 6. and so this
simplifies to
negative 5
minus 6 is negative 11
negative 11
plus 16 gets us to positive five so all
of this simplifies to positive five
and then we have
plus 20
plus four should we do that green color
so we don't get confused
so we have plus 20
plus 4
minus 6. so what does this get is 5 plus
20 is 25 plus 4 is 29
minus 6
29 minus 6 gets us to 23.
so our determinant right over here is
equal to
is equal to
23.
so now we are really in the home stretch
the inverse of this matrix is going to
be 1 over our determinant times the
transpose of this cofactor matrix and
the transpose of the cofactor matrix is
called the adject so let's do that so
let's write the adjective here so c
inverse this is the drum roll we're
really in the home stretch c inverse is
equal to 1 over the determinant so it's
equal to 1 over 23
times the adject
the adjective
of c
and so this is going to be equal to
1 over 23 1 over 23 times the transpose
of our cofactor matrix
so we have our cofactor matrix right
over here so each row now becomes a
column
so this
row
this row
now becomes a column so it becomes 1
negative 7
5 becomes the first column
the second row
becomes the second column
eighteen
negative eleven
negative two
and then finally the third row becomes
the third column
you have negative four
and 3.
and now we just have to multiply or we
could say divide each of these by 23 and
we are there so this is going to be
equal to this is the inverse of our
original matrix c home stretch 1 divided
by 23 is just 1
20 thirds then you have 18 20 thirds
actually let me give myself a little bit
more real estate to do this in
give myself a little bit more real
estate
so there we go so 1 divided by 23 1 23
20 thirds
negative 4
negative seven
twenty thirds negative eleven twenty
thirds
five
twenty thirds
twenty thirds negative two
twenty thirds and then finally assuming
we haven't made any careless mistakes
which would shock me if we haven't
we get to three
twenty thirds and we are done we have
successfully inverted a three by three
matrix once again something i strongly
believe better done by a computer and
probably should not be part of a typical
algebra ii curriculum
because it tend it tends to be displayed
in a kind of non-contextual way